we are here joined at the desk by a
design Duo and power couple meow Nate
Perkins and Jeremiah
[Music]
such a big day around here and because
we are talking about the hottest design
Trends on the internet we want to know
if you guys would like to play a game
love them or leave them this is design
fling or the real thing yeah
I really love this first story I have to
tell you architectural digest of which
your beautiful home is on the cover are
drool no big deal reports wall-to-wall
carpeting is trending after singer Lily
Allen and her husband actor David Harper
revealed that they got wall-to-wall
plush where they flush that's right
they've got carpet in the bathroom
guys no better authority to ask design
fling or the real thing well
well yeah come on so here's the thing
and I'm I can't believe I'm sharing this
but we rented a house a long time ago
and it had a carpeted bathroom and it
was one of the most comfortable things
I've ever since
I mean it's first of all it was so
luxurious
I would never do it again yeah but it
was great if you can't clean that no
there's not enough no no no it makes me
nervous it's a pdz which means potential
dribble Zone you know what I mean I'm
not
in that area for me is it
I mean everywhere is really a potential
but the bathroom is like a high priority
yeah Frankie got out of the shower last
night and um the floor had this much
water on it so I'm just thinking back to
last night and how disgusting that
carpet would be but it's nice to know
that it's a secret guilty pleasure I
mean it was great can you imagine you're
like freezing you step out and your feet
go so cozy it's so nice yeah yeah I just
love that you were judging it when you
saw it and then you just fell in love
with it yeah all right so I mean it's a
it's a it's a fling it's a flame it's a
plane it's a fling but you want it and
now we all know what they want you're
getting one double where you dribble
yeah
The Wall Street Journal reports slip
covers for your sofa they're now Chic
again grandmas you are Vindicated they
say a slip cover and a fun pattern can
give any saggy old sofa a total makeover
plus they're easy to clean so you can
still eat a saucy soupy bowl of
spaghetti on your couch and enjoy it are
they tacky is it a fling or is it the
real thing I'm in a sub cover right now
yeah really yes yep I mean watch I love
slip cover we love it I love it Chic I'm
fine with it I'm doing it a ton for my
firm it's fun it's easy I don't know and
it can it's you could play around with
it doesn't have to all be like very old
so to be clear it's not really a money
saver unless you're a great sewer
because no because the upholstery needs
really the same amount of fabric and it
takes them just as long to measure and
make a slip cover as it does to rip all
that fabric off your sofa and recover it
oh but
um so it's not like a big savings you
could buy inexpensive cover furniture
and it reads a lot more expensive that's
true you're talking about custom slip
covers yeah I'm talking about run down
to Costco get one of those a one size
fits exactly tuck it yeah
that thing that looks like Spanx no
first of all be careful what you say
about this right no way yeah I hate no
no not that the thing that looks like a
cat's butt with like all the wrinkles on
the side
I'm just saying design fling or the real
thing real thing Perfect all right next
delish reports tick tock's latest design
obsession is in a nook and cranny of
your home that you might have forgotten
to decorate oh it's the inside of your
refrigerator check out these people are
fully arranging their Seltzer cans and
yogurts and maybe going a little extra
extra by some floral touches I am the
one had a frame photo of a cat this is
the dumbest thing I've ever seen what oh
my God
too much time on your head
go volunteer are you kidding go read the
kids I don't get a soup kitchen this is
so stupid you can still do those things
no you can't not if you're like sitting
there like putting all your peppers in a
pile and like picking out a frame I
don't like it either it smells like yes
to me yeah it sounds dirty it's gross I
don't get it now organization in the
fridge some bins
um like that I will stand there for
hours and be like oh the coconut water
somebody came in and put it over there
oh yeah do you know what it is guilty
pleasure what's his guilty pleasure it's
just organization videos and just people
organizing videos holding you should be
grateful I'm sitting here looking at
people fold sweatpants
a real thing
um next up speaking of untapped design
space house and Gardens UK reports the
latest canvas is your ceiling yeah this
is actually one of the oldest design
tricks in the books I mean Hello Sistine
Chapel right right if you can't get
Michelangelo to paint you a fresco why
not try like a floral wallpaper or a
bold accent color basically like they
treat the ceiling as the fifth wall yeah
is this something you do in design all
the time we love those I love it yeah do
you consider the ceiling a fifth wall
absolutely absolutely and I think it
could be a lot of fun as long as it's
rooted in what's happening in the rest
of the house and it's just not just some
random outline yeah exactly it's got to
have to be part of the cohesive story
it's also great for renters if you want
to put up like an adhesive wallpaper and
you want to add some type of Personality
um it's fun like you said Ross it's like
it you know it's been going on for
thousands of years so the idea that I
don't mind a white ceiling I love a
white ceiling I think it's fine I don't
think it's obligatory nothing in design
is but like you know people had beams
they add wall covering they add molding
they had that's all part of that so it's
just another moment to express yourself
and I don't think it should be
overlooked you can choose to just keep
it white obviously but near near antique
mirror yeah
that was about yeah yeah well you always
look great by the way that's a really
good angle I've never experienced no you
just look up and walk out the door and
go wow I'm wasting away yeah okay so
design fling or the real thing real
thing all right great well that
[Applause]
project Wednesdays on HGTV and Discovery
plus we'll be right back
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]